this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skill share learn to think
like a lawyer for free for two months by
clicking the link in the description
Michael Cohen testified in front of
Congress for over seven hours I have
some thoughts
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer today we are covering the
testimony of Michael Cohen
president Trump's former personal lawyer
and longtime legal and extra legal fixer
because Cohen testified for so long I
can't cover absolutely everything that
happened in the hearing this is going to
be a compilation of the different things
that I think are particularly
interesting so I want to point out some
of the legal principles that I think are
incredibly important during this hearing
but I also want to point out some of the
rhetorical devices that Cohen himself
and Congress people on either side of
the aisle are using to make their points
and ask effective and sometimes not
effective questions of Cohen now it's
important to recognize that there are
several purposes to this hearing and it
also depends on what particular side
you're playing for the first is to
confirm or dispute the actual testimony
of Michael Cohen so much of what he said
in the hearing was already out in the
news but there's a big difference
between speculation about what he may
testify to an actual evidence in the
form of his testimony on the record
under oath the second is to get
additional information that you had no
idea existed before the inside story
that only Michael Cohen is privy to and
so for the Democrats perspective I'm
sure that they want to get both evidence
of illegal conduct but also things that
are just embarrassing and potentially
don't necessarily rise to the level of
illegality but are just bad for the
Republicans and the President himself on
the other hand the Republicans want new
information to discredit Michael Cohen
and to show the world why no one should
believe him and the third purpose is to
get your message out regardless of the
testimony that Cowan gave you knew that
a lot of the politicians were going to
grandstand because the world was
watching and it was a forum to get their
message out whether you wanted to
discredit the investigation or whether
you wanted to bolster it now as always I
want the comments to have a vigorous but
civil discussion remember that Stella is
watching all of your comments and she
the banhammer of truth so make sure all
of your comments are stella appropriate
all right so let's dig into the
testimony of michael cohen in front of
congress some will certainly ask if mr.
cohen was lying then why should we
believe him now this is a legitimate
question i have made it bundled ly clear
to mr. Cohen that if he comes here today
and he does not tell him the truth tell
us the truth I will be the first one to
refer that uh those untruthful sabers to
DOJ so one of the things that
congressman Cummings is doing here is
what we call front running which is when
you know you have a bad fact or there is
bad evidence out there the worst thing
that you can possibly do is hide it and
pretend it doesn't exist so he's getting
out in front of that bad fact and laying
the groundwork for why we should believe
Cohen now and trying to take the sting
out of the Republican attack this is a
classic and very important trial tactic
that he's using here mr. Trump did not
directly tell me to lie to Congress
that's not how he operates
in conversations we had during the
campaign at the same time I was actively
negotiating in Russia for him he would
look me in the eye and tell me there's
no Russian business and then go on to
lie to the American people it's really
interesting to me that Cohen says
specifically that Trump did not
explicitly direct him to lie to Congress
you would think that if he really was
engaging in scorched earth tactics he
might as well just say that Trump
directed him to do it that probably
would get him a better deal with the
investigators and prosecutors but in
credibility is incredibly important and
for him to go out but not all the way he
possibly could that helps bolster his
credibility and help silence critics
that he's just simply arguing over sour
grapes about not getting a job at the
White House because mr. Trump had made
clear to me through his personal
statements to me that we both knew to be
false and through his lies to the
country
that he wanted me to lie and he made it
clear to me because his personal
attorneys reviewed my statement before I
gave it to Congress this is huge I mean
this alone is quite a bombshell that
President Trump's personal attorneys
reviewed Cohen's statement which is
verifiably false to Congress and is one
of the reasons that Cohen is going to
jail number one I would suggest that
those attorneys lawyer up if they
haven't done so already because it's
entirely possible that if they knew that
the changes that they made to Michael
Cohen's testimony were false they can be
liable in guilty of suborning perjury
and the prosecutors are able to show
that the president was aware of and
directed his attorneys to make those
changes that can make the president
guilty of suborning perjury there are
some pretty heavy intent requirements
there it was recently reported that
Michael Cohen has given Congress copies
of the changes that president Trump's
attorneys made to his statement that
gave rise to him pleading guilty to
lying to Congress those statements could
be incredibly damning I would not expect
any of those statements to be protected
by attorney-client privilege because I
think the joint defense agreement has
been breached and I don't think the
attorney-client or product protection
would apply because of the crime fraud
exception so if I was the president's
attorney I would be very worried about
what those documents show to Congress I
wound up touting the Trump narrative for
over a decade that was my job always
stay on message always defend it
monopolized my life at first I worked
mostly on real estate developments and
other business transactions shortly
thereafter mr. Trump brought me into his
personal life and private dealings a lot
of people have asked me how it is that
Michael Cohen can testified to
communications he had with mr. Trump
before he became president since Michael
Cohen is an attorney and communications
with attorneys are supposed to be
protected well it's a great question but
it's one that's very easily answered
attorney-client protections only protect
communications that are made between
attorneys and their client
when attorneys are acting as an attorney
if you have an attorney friend who is
working as an employee or a business
person just because they're an attorney
that doesn't necessarily mean that
attorney-client privilege will attach
and Michael Cohen for most of his career
it appears that he was rarely acting as
an attorney and was really just acting
mostly as an extra legal thug and
potentially as a business person a
business associate so all of those
communications that mr. Cohen had with
mr. Trump when mr. Cohen was not acting
in his capacity as an actual lawyer are
not protected by attorney-client
privilege when he was president of the
United States pursuant to the cover-up
which was the basis of my guilty plea to
reimburse me the word used by mr.
Trump's TV lawyer for the illegal hush
money I paid on his behalf
this $35,000 check was one of 11 check
installments that was paid throughout
the year while he was president other
checks to reimburse me for the hush
money payments were signed by Donald
Trump jr. and Alan weiselberger so this
is fairly damning evidence from Michael
Cohen that the President of the United
States his son Donald Trump jr. and the
CFO of the Trump Organization all
engaged in a criminal conspiracy to
engage in collection and financial fraud
by hiding these payments in order to
prevent that information from becoming
public and potentially affecting the
outcome of the election we have of
course known about this for quite some
time now but Michael Cohen is going to
jail for his part in this criminal
conspiracy and it's hard to imagine how
that doesn't apply to Donald Trump jr.
the President or Alan Y Solberg as well
Cohen states that this conspiracy
existed before the election was designed
to affect the election and it continued
into the presidency when Donald Trump
signed a personal check while he was
president there's just no way to
sugarcoat this it's hard to see how more
people aren't going to go to jail over
this particular act if not others since
Michael Cohen is already going to jail
for
I have provided the committee with
copies of tweets that mr. Trump posted
attacking me and my family and only
someone burning his head in the sand
would not recognize them for what they
are it's an encouragement to someone to
do harm to me and my family yeah so the
presidential tweets that surrounded this
testimony including some tweets from
congressmen like congressman Matt Gaetz
were so borderline witness intimidation
that you have to wonder what they were
thinking when they made those statements
here
Cohen isn't establishing that they
constitute witness tampering
that requires showing that the person
who put those statements forward
intended and had a corrupt motive to
prevent the witness from testifying
but Cohen is at least testifying that he
took those communications to be a form
of witness intimidation and was in fact
intimidated by them so it is at least
laying a groundwork for further
investigations to probe what in the
world the point of those those tweets
were how long did you work in the White
House I never worked in the White House
that's the point isn't it mr. Cohen no
sir yes it is no it's not so you wanted
to work in the White House no sir he can
get brought to the dance sir now I was
extremely proud to be personal attorney
to the President of the United States of
America I did not want to go to the
White House so this is a good example of
not asking questions that you don't know
the answer to Congressman Jim Jordan
here wants to make the point that all of
this is sour grapes Michael Cohen wanted
a job at the White House he didn't get
one and as a result he is now turning
against the president I don't know if
that's true or not but what I can tell
you is that he opened up the door for
Michael Cohen to opine and give his own
story about what happened he wanted to
make a speech but he gave Cohen the
opportunity to directly contradict all
of the points that he was trying to make
and on top of that congressman Jordan is
acting in a fairly aggressive way which
is a tactic that can sometimes work but
it rarely does especially where the
witness is not acting hostile in in any
way how many times did the President
Michael ask you or direct you to try to
reach settlements with women in 2015 and
2016 I'm sorry ma'am I don't I don't
have the answer to that I'd have to go
back and try to recollect it's certainly
the two that we know about and why why
do you think the president did not
provide the accurate information in his
2017 financial disclosure form so that
was a good example of an open end
question from congresswoman Maloney
getting at how many mistresses mr. Trump
had before he was elected and how many
times he paid them off she didn't get
the answer that she wanted to but
unfortunately she didn't really follow
up either when a witness testifies that
he or she is not particularly sure about
something you should always go back and
you should try and get the specifics
Koen testifies that there are at least
the two the simple follow-up question is
are there other women that you are aware
of are there other women that he did not
pay off
are there other instances that might
have led to blackmail are there other
instances of inappropriate payments to
women or other people that might have
relevant testimony so often in this
hearing the Democratic Congress people
we're not listening to the answers that
Cohen was giving he clearly wanted to
get a story out whether you believe that
story is a different question
but he was giving them information that
they wanted and he probably would have
given them much much more information if
they had just followed up you made some
very demeaning comments about the the
president that Miss Patten doesn't agree
with in fact it has to do with your
claim of racism
she says that as a daughter of a man
born in Birmingham Alabama that there is
no way that she would work for it for an
individual who was racist how do you
reconcile the two of those neither
should i as
son of a Holocaust survivor there's a
lot going wrong with what congressman
Meadows was trying to do here when you
have a demonstrative which effectively
he was making miss patent out to be a
demonstrative exhibit here
you always have to be worried about what
people are going to do that because
you're opening yourself up to further
criticism based on the thing that you
are putting out there you can't defeat
an accusation of racism by holding out
one single black woman who you have
employed as if that defeats that
accusation it just simply doesn't it's
bordering on tokenism in and of itself
and number two you don't know how cohen
is going to react to this particular
gambit this is a lawyer's worst
nightmare
congressman meadows really should have
thought out the repercussions of
bringing out miss patton in this
particular venue just to make a note mr.
chairman that just because someone has a
person of color a black person working
for them does not mean they are racist
and it is insensitive that someone would
even say racist they say it is racist in
itself and to use a black woman as a
prop to move to prove it otherwise and i
can submit this for the record if a
colleague is thinking that that's what
i'm saying i'm just saying that's what i
believe to have happened and if as a
person of color in this committee that's
how I felt at that moment and I wanted
to express that but I am not calling the
gentleman mr. meadows a racist for doing
so I'm saying that in itself it is a
racist act well I hope not mr. chairman
because I need to be clear on this
particular mr. chairman so this is a
great example of the Streisand effect
and why you don't make a big stink about
something that you don't want to
emphasize here congressman meadows is
upset about the implication from
congresswoman Talib that he engaged in
racial tokenism by trotting out Lynne
Patten to refute the allegation of
racism by Donald Trump instead of
letting sleeping dogs lie he makes a big
deal about it which allows congresswoman
Talib to read her exact same statement
again and really emphasize the point
that it was a stupid gambit to make in
the first place so if you don't want to
emphasize something don't make a huge
deal about it that is the Streisand
effect in
raishin to your knowledge did the
President or his company ever inflate
assets or revenues yes and was that done
with the president's knowledge or
Direction everything was done with the
knowledge and at the direction of mr.
Trump now a lot of this hearing focused
on asset and revenue inflation by the
Trump Organization for the purposes of
loans and and other financial dealings
we try to get a loan from the bank it's
the bank's job to accurately value the
property that's being put forth so it's
not surprising that people try and use
very optimistic valuations of their own
property in order to get a loan however
revenue inflation is something that the
bank might not be able to double check
the company is the one that contains the
revenue numbers
so while asset inflation is not a good
thing it rarely gives rise to financial
fraud revenue inflation on the other
hand is financial fraud and could carry
with it lots of different kinds of
liability so I wish that the Congress
people had differentiated between the
two because they focused mainly on asset
inflation as opposed to revenue
inflation so you don't commit to
changing your ways basically because you
want to continue to use your background
as a liar a cheater a convicted liar to
make money that's what you want to do
and that's going to get me a book deal
in a movie deal and television and a
spot on television
I don't think so the Republicans focused
a lot on a potential book or movie deal
from Cohen that's an interesting tactic
for going after his bias the more
information Cohen gives in this setting
the less valuable a book or movie deal
would be later on on the other hand the
more famous he can become and the more
central of a player he is in this whole
scenario potentially that makes book or
movie deal more lucrative so it cuts
both ways but I'm not sure that that
means we should not believe Cohen here
so I'm not sure it achieves the purpose
that they're trying to establish here
the idea that a witness would come to us
who's flawed and you certainly are
flawed
means they can never tell the truth and
there is no validity whatsoever to a
single word they say would discredit
every single krug criminal trial of
organized crime in the history of the
United States because all of them depend
on someone who's turned so this hearing
raises a really interesting issue that
comes up in trial all the time which is
what do you do when you put a known liar
up on the stand well if you're the
proponent of the witness then you have
to explain the witness's motivation for
why they were lying before and why they
can be trusted now and then the most
important thing you can do is bolster
their current testimony with documents
have independent ways of verifying what
they are testifying now is the truth now
if you are the other side and you're
trying to dispute the evidence of
someone who has lied before
you obviously harp on the fact that they
we did in fact lie and you should not
trust them now but you also have to
establish reasons for why they would
continue to lie at the present date so
for example if you were dealing with a
confidential informant in a criminal
trial you would want to harp on the fact
that whatever carrot the prosecution is
offering to this witness is a reason for
them to make up new information if the
confidential informant didn't have new
information to give the prosecution
their testimony would be worthless so
they have an incentive to continue to
lie so of course the Republicans here
are harping on the fact that Cohen lied
before and cannot be trusted now they
have a difficult job here because the
lies that Michael Cohen told were for
the benefit of the president especially
with respect to the length and duration
of the Trump Tower Moscow negotiations
so every time the Republicans raise the
issue of Cohen's prior bad deeds whether
it's lying or whether it is threatening
people with lawsuits or whether it is
illegally paying funds to pay off porn
star mistresses it raises the specter of
who benefited from all of those acts and
in almost every single instance the
benefit of those lies and illegal
conduct is the President of the United
States the person the Republicans
presumably want to protect so I don't
know if there is another theme that the
Republicans could have gone with during
this hearing but the theme that they
went with which is that Michael Cohen is
a brute and a liar is true and certainly
damning but it's also damning to the
person they're trying to protect the
president in this particular case is
there any other wrongdoing or illegal
act that you are aware of regarding
Donald Trump that we haven't yet today
yes and again those are part of the
investigation that's currently being
looked at by the Southern District of
New York man
so that testimony is a bombshell in and
of itself
Cohen has testified that he is aware of
other criminal acts that surround
President Trump what I really wish the
congressman would have done is follow up
you could ask how many criminal acts is
Cohen aware of whether there are other
people that have not been indicted yet
who are responsible for those criminal
acts and perhaps Cohen would respond
with the same answer that says I can't
talk about that because there's an
ongoing investigation with the Southern
District of New York but that's a good
answer for the Democrats it isn't it
also true that convicted Russian mobster
later even had business cards indicating
that he was a senior advisor to Donald
Trump as reported by the Washington Post
yes did convicted Russian mobster Seder
pay rent for his office no he did not
so what I want to point out the
congressman is doing here is he's
repeating a theme he's asking questions
about Felix seder and every time he says
the name Felix seder he says convicted
Russian mobster Felix seder
it might sound ridiculous but over time
it sticks in your head so every time you
think of the name Felix aider you're
gonna think of oh he's a convicted
Russian mobster of course the person who
does that the most is probably President
Trump himself where he will give
nicknames to individuals to engender
certain ideas and emotions about
individuals by repeating that name that
he has created for them so that's what
he's trying to do here let me ask you
this mr. Cohen have you done have you
legally or illegally recorded other
clients I have recordings of people yes
lately or illegally I believe that
they're legal
did you tell
in New York State you don't have to do
that though you didn't tell them no I
did not
these are interesting questions as a
practicing lawyer Michael Cohen recorded
his clients conversations with him as
Cohen actually correctly points out New
York is a one-party consent state which
means the person who was recording is
the one that consents to the recording
and therefore you don't have to notify
other people it is unusual for a lawyer
to record his clients but it may not in
and of itself be illegal if I was a
client I certainly wouldn't want that
and I don't think I would hire an
attorney who who did record his clients
but as an ethical violation or as a
legal matter I'm not sure that it's
illegal I'd have to check but my
instinct is that in and of itself it's
probably not illegal so in your
testimony on page 13 you claim and I
quote mr. Trump directed me to use my
own personal funds from a home equity
line of credit to avoid any money being
tracked back to him that could
negatively impact his campaign do you
have any proof of this direction this is
always a bad question do you have any
proof the question assumes that there
could be one single piece of evidence
that absolutely proves a particular
point when in reality when you're trying
to prove something you use lots of tiny
steps to ultimately get to your end
result and in response to a question of
you don't have any proof the witness
could just go off for days about all of
the different pieces of evidence that
support the things that he's trying to
say while not absolutely in one
particular step proving the ultimate
idea so number one Cohen does have proof
in the form of different kinds of
evidence to support his case and number
two you don't know how he's going to
answer this question he's not going to
give up the ghost and admit oh I have no
corroborating evidence whatsoever so
it's a bad question to ask and it's
something that I find particularly
annoying as an attorney okay those are
my thoughts about the Cohen hearing this
is more group therapy than it is a legal
explainer Michael Cohen is going to jail
for a long time but he could put that
time to good use by learning a new skill
especially since he's been disbarred by
the state of New York for example he'd
really benefit from Simon van Bois
Skillshare
on six steps to a successful writing
habit he could channel all the time he
used to spend writing letters
threatening colleges not to release
president Trump's grades into creative
writing and copies of letters I wrote at
mr. Trump's direction that threatened
his high school colleges and the college
board not to release his grades or SAT
scores or he could take rocks and gaze
class on crafting personal essays with
impact it would really help him write
that rule 35 motion to reduce his prison
sentence for good behavior it is for the
benefit of a rule 35 motion yes
Skillshare is an online learning
community that has over 20,000 classes
on everything like lifestyle design and
technology
the first 500 legal eagles will get two
free months of Skillshare when you click
on the link below the free premium
membership gives you unlimited access to
must know topics so you can improve your
skills and learn new things it could
even get you out of jail earlier like
Michael Cohen so click on the link get
two free months and start learning to
think like a lawyer today so do you
agree leave your objections in the
comments check out my other real law
reviews over here and until next time I
will see you in court